so i actually went to js conf 2012 i
attended it um
it was my first conference ever as
anything and i sat there totally shy
never talked to a person single person
so if you told me that this year i'd be
up on stage presenting then uh
i would have been very surprised
um i
sent this tweet out this
morning um
what have jack carra jane austin james
joyce richard feynman arthur condor
simon johnson
ernest hemingway got in common and
the reason i sent that is because i hope
someone would have a really clever
answer for me so i could say on stage
but i got this which is pretty good
because um
they all work hoverscript right
which which actually as you'll see is
not as far from the truth as you might
think
so um
this talk um
started way back august 2012
um i was talking to a friend on irc and
he asked what i was doing and i said oh
uh i just wrote a piece of javascript in
the style of of of of ernest
hemingway
and he was like great you should write
blog posts and it was a and i'd actually
hadn't written a piece of javascript in
the style of ernest henry i was just
thinking about how that would work i
hadn't done it at all
i thought oh crap now i have to go and
write it so i did
and it became a blog post and it became
a very successful post and on the front
of hacker monthly and a bunch of other
stuff
so from that um came this talk
and
today i'm going to present i'm going to
have code reviews from five authors
the five authors in that talk
um
and plus
especially for this talk i promise to
write another five
doing another exercise
um i got seven in the end i couldn't
narrow it down so hopefully we have time
um
so uh here are here's the mother of all
code reviews
these authors sent me back code sent me
back
from history
the
their answers to two problems and we're
going to do a code review on them
so exercise one is
fibonacci numbers return the fibonacci
sequence for the argument given argument
which is the number the size of the
sequence
first up is ernest hemingway these are
all quotes these are all actual actual
quotes
actually they they really are i just
changed a
single word each time sometimes they
didn't even change any anything
and i think these quotes go a little bit
a little
bit of the way towards explaining
their approach to solving the problem so
let's look at ernest's um attempt at
solving fibonacci so those of you who
know hemingway he's very spare um he uh
he he is very economical
he only tells you what you have to know
there were no comments because he was a
proponent of the iceberg theory which is
that
the minimum possible amount is on the
surface the rest is for the
reader to discover
hidden
beneath the surface
um
very straightforward
he names his
variables exactly as you would expect
first second
not trying to be clever
not trying to use any terminology any
technical
terminology
uh it's a really nice solution uh if the
size is less than two fibonacci
um
you know he could give you the answer
but he feels
you were an idiot for asking so
that's what you're gonna get back
next up is uh shakespeare
that is an actual that's an actual q
quote from shakespeare
um
so he kind of drags this this one out as
only shakespeare can
um
calculation in two acts employing the
humorous logic of javascript
and he introduces the
characters he has the dramatis
personae the main protagonists are the
result
which is an array which is going to
return to you
and the counter
as he can so we can count through the
for loop and as only shakespeare would
well not actually is only shakespeare
but as shakespeare did he
divided this into into acts
so act one let's see if there's magic
scrolling words yes
so act one um in which the zero is added
for it
initiation
uh which is just a long way of saying
he's assigning zero to the result and by
the way
um almost all of his comment comments
are in iambic
pentameter which is the way shakespeare
wrote um
thank you
which is ten syllables basically per
line
um
stress every other syllable hence
pentameter
five syllables stressed
he didn't always stick exactly to that
and he hasn't in the comments the point
is to emphasize certain words by by
switching the stress
um
to those words so let's go right on to
act two
in which
um
every iteration the loop two numbers are
queried and summed
and by divination he sets uh joining
members as as he says
and um
it's it's pretty nice code i guess um
there's a bit of obfuscation going on um
the reason he's doing result
mathematics
zero down there is that um
he
doesn't want zero or
one to be counted there so that that's
what he's doing there and then finally
um
he returns the result to you
and then the
players exit and that's the end
now um
who's heard of andre
breton uh he was a mid-century french
surrealist
uh one of the founding members of the
surrealist movement and he believed
dreams were more interesting than
he
was being to
so all his pros have a very dreamlike
quality to them and he actually
switches nouns for
any other word he can think of
so this is what we get
so uh factorial he renames factorial to
colette which presumably refers to an
old
claim of his
uh but the amazing thing is and why i
really like his writing is there's a
certain elegance to it i mean he chooses
his nouns carefully
um and there's a certain
logic logic to it you'll see he has
staircase for the iterator the thing
that that you that you
he meant
and i think all in all he's done pretty
nicely here it's a very nice answer
um next um on to the
chilean also roberto
palano who's one of my personal
favorites
um
and bolano uh has a wonderful style he's
charmingly
naive um incredibly honest and
every aspect of human
frailty is included he'll tell you what
he's thinking the whole the whole time
the most personal um seemingly
uninteresting thoughts he'll he'll he'll
share with you so you see his comments
uh very much in that in that kind of
stuff also
uh he loved the old poets and the old
writers any historical figure so he's
actually named his factorial after a
certain leonardo pisano
piccolo who was actually the
person who credited with
identifying the
fibonacci series
um
so
if l is less than zero l being the size
here if l is less than zero uh he he
doesn't want to answer that because he
doesn't know how to answer although he
admits that several
responses uh probably not very nice
responses occur to him and then he just
writes the code and he doesn't really
care about the code if you read his
books like the plot is
almost a sideline so he just
he he just
writes the code in short order um and
then
um
says he doesn't really understand what's
going on and then he he
he lists a lot of mathematicians which
really interests him um
and this is his kind of deal this this
is how he works
in his books uh he pays
homage to these people
and then he returns the answer
he said i didn't really know how any of
this thing worked but anyway here's the
answer in case you're interested and
he's so damn honest he's like he can't
help looking a bit further down the page
even though actually actually nothing
happens and he just points out that
there was nothing happening and he would
rather not talk about it even if it was
this is a very personal style of his
so on to uh charles charles dickens um
charles dickens i don't really like his
work that much he's very superficial
henry james called him the greatest of
super superficial novelists
uh i think he has a lack of substance at
heart he's very good at building um
characters he has great great characters
but he doesn't do anything with them to
my mind and
um there's a lack of honesty and a lack
of understanding i think somewhere there
so we can see what he does here is he
uh ignores the principle of the
fibonacci series in fact adventure that
he doesn't really understand it
but he did notice that
um
every number in the series is almost
exactly 1.61803
times the previous number in the series
so again very superficially he just used
that to build the series
and there we have it so
that is that and now exercise two so
those are all those are all the five
posts from the previous blog that i
wrote um these now are seven code
reviews that have
just been sent to me
uh for the next exercise so i've no idea
what's on these so i'll i'll be seeing
it for the first first time too
exercise two is uh
factorial so if a given argument n
return the factorial
and let's start with
correct
jack
kerovac
um now kerouac had a very
uh
spontaneous
stream of conscious style
and he didn't think ahead
so there isn't a function here
like
he thank you
so
he
it looks like he hasn't actually
prepared any other examples it would
only work for n equals
43.
um
and he's put a whole lot of comments in
here too and it's really hard to figure
out what is code and what is comment
but it actually sort of works
there's a kind of stream there and and
there is answer he actually tells you
the answer uh
before he gives it you uh
so there we are that's jack correct so
yeah i mean it's okay
so here is james joyce um
this is a particularly nice quote
actually of his
uh i don't know how many you're familiar
with him with the
writings of james joyce but one thing he
liked to do a lot was
make up these portmanteau words which is
like two words combined
and it looks like he's actually taking
that into his code and he's using that
in a lot of places so
this is a hack on the factorial utility
so he's called it a hacktorial
and he wants you to pass a small in to
jurors the argument because a big
integer it's not it's just going to blow
the whole thing up so that's why he's
calling it an in
jet to hint strongly that small integers
should be passed
uh he's returning a list of
policies here assigning it not sure why
he's doing that actually because it
doesn't really help but
whatever that's that's the way he thinks
i guess he's got the
there's altitudin which is like the the
amalgam of results and
computation
um
now if you pass
zero in no one really understands to be
honest the y the factorial of zero is
equal to
one it's just one of those things so
this is behold the stranger is steroid
it's like the strange and dangerous
hero that no one really understands and
i'm just gonna hard code that
and then uh caligulate by multi-capables
i don't even know what he's saying there
but i guess what he's doing is he's just
doing um straightforward uh for loop
uh counting down and multiplying up
everything that he finds
um and that's the answer really but it
looks like he's done something else here
um what's he doing
oh okay he's um
yeah
he he's converting it to shillings and
pence which is the the currency that was
around at the time he was actually
writing
now actually when you think about this
this makes some sense because every
factorial over four i think is divisible
by 12
and there are 12 shillings in 12 pennies
in a shilling
so he realizes that shillings is a
pretty good way to express results for
factorial
um he's doing a lot of um crazy you
see he doesn't actually use functions in
as function declaration he uses a
constructor he uses a function
constructor here
um
god only knows why
uh but it seems it seems to work and and
then he um
and then he he passes all the
non-alpha characters out of there and
then he gets the answer oh and he always
likes to throw in these super
portmanteaus right at the end which is
like a whole bunch of stuff combined all
that uh clicker-clacker stuff
that's just how he writes you know i
don't know
so there we have some some examples
there
and it's actually yeah it's okay it's
okay
and now we have uh
richard feynman
who's not a
novelist or a
poet but a very interesting guy i have a
great respect for him especially the way
um and this quote sums it up
and i think this is going to sum up his
approach the answer is he never pays
attention to anything by x but
programs everything himself and to that
end
he used this approximation
to calculate factorial and hence he's
called it factorial or actually fractal
rail
um
because it doesn't just work for
integers it works for f
factions too
uh i think it's pretty damn clever um
very scientific approach
and so there we can see we can see and
the the only problem is it's only an
approximation
so
i'm sure we're all kind of familiar with
this um
3 is zero zero zero five but now he can
cleverly do um factorials of
of
non-integers too which is really great
um
now we have arthur conan doyle
who um the author of the sherlock holmes
stories and
i think um he's done something a little
bit odd here he's he he likes to solve
problems he likes to work
backwards through the problems so
factorial doesn't interest him he wants
give me the answer to the factorial and
i will give you the un factorial i will
work
backwards to determine what was the
number that actually ceded this
factorial
um he uses a couple of things at the
beginning he just says well you won't
understand these first two so i'm just
going to put them in a hard-coded hash
and then he gets to the real um
factorial function
and he was a humble guy basically
well
um he was humble here and and if
the number one is the argument then he
doesn't know what it could be because it
could be zero or it
could be one so he says to watson
he is at a loss
and then um second his second um
uh part his methodology was to look for
logical president have we ever had a
case like this go back through the case
history we haven't had one like this
before because he's cashing all of the
old answers he straight away looks in
the case history
and finds the old solutions there
and then he eliminates the impossible so
um actually any factorial over four
which is all we're left with now is
divisible by 24. so unless it's if it if
it's uh zero or not divisible by 24
then he says charlatans
this is not the answer to a
factorial finally
uh he knows it's a real factorial and he
will work backwards and deduce the
answer
but even then if it doesn't come up to a
whole number or so if um
the denominator numerator and
denominator do not match by continually
dividing the numerator by denominator
then he knows you're an imposter too and
that wasn't a real factorial and then he
adds it to the case history and then he
returns the answer
that's very good okay now and here's
some examples for you
now um
hamill johnson
simon johnson was a 17th century uh
writer some of you may have heard of him
he composed a dictionary he wrote the
first dictionary or one of the first
first dictionaries back in 1700s
and he had a very famous quote when one
is tired of javascript one is
tired of life
and
the thing about samuel johnson is he
hung around
coffee shops a lot
he did always work in coffee shops and
also he um
he really did not like the elaborate
language his contemporaries were using
they tended to use um elaborate somewhat
historical language and he liked very
clean
very clipped kind of language so
coffeescript was perfect for him
so he's used coffeescript to solve the
problem
the irony is he liked very simple
language when we look back now on how he
used to write it looks kind of
old-fashioned and and interesting um
he's a bit sarcastic um ingenious soft
history to prove that palpably of
ps um
if the number is
if one is the argument then that's the
answer he also took an entry from his
dictionary uh in the put in the comments
so uh recursion
uh he defined that from his dictionary
and uh and you can see a little bit of
like
slightly scathing wit there towards
recursion he's not totally sold on it
but um
it solves his problem
so now uh jane austen and the thing
about jane austen um
was because she
was in a male dominated world
um
she felt she had to hide her cleverness
from the world but she
she did it in a very um
like this is almost a recursive
statement here because
a programmer especially if she has the
most misfortune of knowing anything
she'll conceal it as well as she can
well she's not really saying that she's
concealing the fact that that she knows
you shouldn't do that
um and we can see it a lot in examples
and
um she she parodies a lot she parodies
the conventions of the time and so
you'll see
she parodies um
the
pedentry of the
javascript community
um
the fact that you
some people say you should use triple
equals for everything um she's
pretending she thinks that's actually
true she knows perfectly well it's not
and she doesn't have to do that
she even checks to see whether the
argument is and is an actual number
or not knowing that it could not be a
number
um
yeah and so
there's a certain mr crockford um who
says whenever we have a we have a nave
or a foreign loop we should check for um
in case it was inherited from the
prototype so
um
she's pretending that she thinks you
should that's what you should do here
and then she carries on with cursing
until the answer comes up
uh and it's a very nice we just go back
one um as with her writing it's very
well it's very well crafted
um she's used a self-invoking function
took as a kind of closure
so even the um
caching and everything is completely
enclosed
within this it's a very
tidy function
and then finally um
back to ernest
can't keep him out he wanted to send
again i didn't actually ask him but he
sent me another response to this one so
um
and again
ernest hemingway is very spare very
economical
uh that's how he did it
none of your other
uh extra stuff uh
he doesn't care that he might be
slightly slower the recursive solution
he wants it to be clean
he wants it to be spare and that's why
we have
that's it and here's some resources you
might want to look at
thank you
you